neues thema weil wir das die todesstrafe
in deutschland eingeführt werden sollte
von florid bereit ihre erste der das was
sagen wird es bestimmt den aber damit
ist abstrakt meinung ankommt strafe ob
man jedoch schon länger so dass eine
steinzeitliche mittelalterliche
einstellung so eine religion eine
christliche einstellung auge um auge
zahn um zahn wie es in der bibel steht
wenn ich er ja der hat den getötet jetzt
müssen wir ihn töten ja das ist so wie
damals wurden auch ehrenmorde begann er
hat einer familie getötet sie müssen ihn
töten dann ging es aber so weiter und
dann hat man ihn ende ein bisschen wie
besteht überhaupt religionen also
christentum oder der islam gewalt gewalt
gewalt zwar muss man sich überlegen was
alles für regierung gemacht wird gerd
was für attentat deswegen gibt kriege
nur wegen religion mehr richtig und
wahrscheinlich gibt es so was nicht mehr
wie wetter oder so als nur frei erfunden
damit sowas überhaupt hier ausstellt
nein das ist jetzt nicht meine behaupten
sondern ich habe einfach wahrscheinlich
gibt es nicht weil es gibt es immerhin
nachrichten sehen wir immer thema das
ist ja das alles damals wirklich nur
erfunden wurden dass die leute wirklich
was haben woran sie glauben dann gab es
auch diese ablassbrief im mittelalter wo
er die religion dazu ausgenutzt wurde
um geld zu machen und alles was es da
schon alles gab ich weiß sie ob das
alles noch so gelobt es ist ja alles
menschen gemacht
eure meinung zum thema todesstrafe
ich würde sagen das wäre natürlich leute
die jetzt irgendwie von denen quasi das
kind in mir entführt wurde und getötet
wurde kommt jetzt nicht so oft vor aber
die wird natürlich sage ja sofort ihm
wollen warum bringen aber dann ist es
bei denen wiederum so ihr habt ihn
umgebracht jetzt hier dürfen wir auch
umbringen und so weiter und das ist dann
das artet nachher alles so schnell aus
dass das nicht mehr zu kontrollieren ist
sage ich mal
und man sollte wenn man sagt ja der hat
eine person umgebracht bisher war dem
tod von einer person beteiligten dürfen
jetzt auch umbringen das ist ja da gibt
es komplett andere sachen ob jetzt eine
person fünf monate festgehalten hat kein
hunger also ihm nur ganz wenig zu essen
geben hat richtig gefoltert hat und dann
wird der gleichgesetzt mit der
todesstrafe wie eine person die zum
beispiel einfach nur sag ich mal selbst
psychische probleme hat und deswegen
irgendeine person umgebracht hat weil
keine ahnung es gibt ja alles und wenn
die dann gleich gesetzt werden das wird
nicht mehr zu kontrollieren sein und das
ist allgemein einfach nur
man wird menschen gegeneinander
aufhetzen sage ich mal und das darf man
nicht natürlicherweise strafe in vielen
ländern auch in zivilisierten ländern
amerika in usa dort zwar noch in einigen
staaten durchaus durchgeführt gerne mal
usa es ist auch so dass man in texas
jeder hat das recht eine eigene waffe zu
tragen er und wenn sie noch alles anders
ja das ist so hart kommen wenn das
grundstück ist und der typ sei der
grundstücksbesitzer sagt du sollst jetzt
runter geht wenn du gehst nicht runter
holt er seine knarre und darf ich
abknallen kranker schett wir dürfen
einfach öffentlich mit den waffen herum
auf man da gibt es ja auch so oft sogar
kriege und sowas keine ahnung das gibt
es in deutschland überhaupt nicht wir
die rockerkrieg zwischen den hells
angels und den ja ist näher als man
denkt professor doktor den leuten
erzähle lieblingsessen hatten wir der
zweiten folge wie wer wird eure meinung
deutsche meister dritten wie findet ihr
ein x games zur vierten jetzt noch
fünfter
ach so ok gut dann hatten wir jetzt ok
alles passt sagte garvey einer neuen
folge mit gerade mal vier minuten das
thema geredet
recht schnell gewesen wenn du highlights
macht ganz einfach den ganzen todes so
dar einpacken
ganz ist das denn jetzt gemeint das
nimmst bitte zurück nur bei akut mir
leid lieberlieber denn du bist der beste
auf der welt ist china der goldrichtig
so richtig so
dennoch wird 43 alter wie wir
unterrichten noch gehen auch ich bin die
ganze zeit beim sandfarben auch ganz
interessant wird sich auch so an
ich habe keine items mehr weil sie
irgendwie alle weg sind
die tasten passiert sein fett weg hey
wieso du hast doch du ich hab dich doch
die pet unterlagen deine sachen hast du
dir noch eine art keine ahnung egal
ok ach jetzt in die zombie schuld
minecraft praktiker total hier gerade ja
sollte erst an büro- und unseren idealen
sowie fixe turbo rick carlisle kirmes
das ist für eine harte zeit kate winslet
hatte in seinem ding der cs die conga
schaukel als eingeladene du bist mit 120
km/h und also das ist sein ding das ist
50 meter hoch das angeblich eines der
heftigsten kirmes karussells und wir so
angetrunken
helga 3 mio
da so drin und du willst dann wirklich
in so einer schaukel die dreht sich
selber du dreht sich mein kopf und du
fährst dann quasi nach oben geht es nach
oben geschaukelt und dann wieder runter
unten her und dann wieder eine andere
richtung nach oben
und da unten in unten bis 120 130 km h
auf dich das sind g kräfte da kann den
wirbel aus regen das sind gegenkräfte
hey das kann den wirbel aus trinken und
dann wird es in deutschland zugelassen
würde als tüv kontrolliert alles nehme
deutschland keine leute rein die über
150 oder so einfach etwas über 1 95
ja ich bin 1 98 also ich bin schon
selber so 190 ungefähr und das schon
reicht aber auch bei mir auch
verletzlicher wti kostet 52 deswegen
muss ich muss ich muss hier mal ein
katalog bestellen so über und unter
größen sind da treiben so aus amiland
kommen die dann alle hat ich bin auch so
192 oder so aber ich habe schuhgröße 44
glaub ich
aber weil mir wachsen ist nicht mehr
mein vater hat keine hand viel höher
weiß ich hoffe es
warum ich 53 0 meinte schick mir 52
halte ich war kurze zeit also wäre ich
musste kurz zeit mal so lederschuhe
keine ahnung da waren die abschlussparty
oder sowas lederschuhe und das ist nun
mal so zwei zentimeter für zentimeter
von trun so die spitze und es war so
extrem bordes es war hart soll ich so
schlimm wie konstanz ihn weil das waren
richtige clowns vom clown schuhe
ich wäre übrigens dafür dass wir
zusammen in der mine gehen nicht eine
höhle
ja ja du meinst dann in die mine ja von
mir aus kann es machen holst du mich ab
heute noch einmal kurz ein bisschen holz
abnahm okay was mache ich hier
eigentlich
ich hab mir gerade holz umgebauten
abzubauen weil ich dachte kommt rohholz
raus aber wohl nicht ja ich bin auch
wird sich so ich tue alles ich er ist
durchaus richtig
ich komme auch gleich letzte was du
nicht brauchst so von euch allen noch
leiser bereisen
es wäre auch gut wenn ich chancen hätte
wo eine neue pick exklusiv kann ja gar
nichts geben ich habe mich selber fast
gar nichts nehmen
ich nehm stx auch mit und firma ist ihr
schönes thema ich habe mir letztens war
dein faq angeguckt mit was nimmst du auf
meinem bildschirm mit die extorre steht
er doch sei ja genau ich habe mich
gefragt was willst du nicht hast du mac
pc das nimmt das es verein praktisch
raps und audacity in dem sinne dass du
dass der die tonspur getrennt aufnimmt
das muss ich da kannst du mir vielleicht
privat tutorial führt sohn nimmt man
minecraft aufbewahrt vorstellung
er war mit der höhe der ja ich bin nur
gerade das problem das ich eigentlich
noch reisen braucht ja ich hab selber
etwa eine reise verbraucht habe ein
einziges ich hab nicht mal kohle mine
ein pixum sinne von so so kaputt so gut
denn ich habe einmal mehr steil eisig
brandenstein gerade hat noch
kartenverkauf ich kann mir noch eine
lederweste machen ich hab noch ein
bisschen leder
wo hast du hast die ganzen kühle gekillt
auch mal so wenige paar doch die ganze
zeit welche da und warum machst du leder
noch von vorher hatte ich jetzt in der
kiste
und da soll ich gekillt ja wir hatten
wir nicht mehr kühe sondern die aus der
frei lebenden die frei die freien tiere
also ich bin verstanden
tausend mal besser als der dunkle lord
super den
ich danke ich danke dir ja ich weiß ihr
könnt also ich hab euch abfackeln
wir gehen ja wo ich habe jetzt schon
schwere lassen auch hier ist bei euch
regensburg auch draußen er bei mir ich
denke das war bei mir gerade so vor
allem einer stunde oder so dass mit
firnis ist freilich noch ein crafting
ben stich mit treten kann braucht ihr
holz ich bin deutsch bin ich hab gerade
mir selbst hält muss man ganz hin
kann mir jemand mal holz zu werfen
sonst muss ein crafting fällt aus er
habe ich nicht genug holz oder muss ich
mir was machen soll dann habe ich und
dann hab ich ne crafting menschen dann
können wir loslegen könnt ihr mal gucken
welche richtung wir gehen wollen
ja aber es war die idee und zu aber ich
brauche allzu viel ändern
du kannst dich bei sportings battling a
ha ich bin kein höherer karten schwein
wartet wartet hatte einstein die ich
verfolgt ein schwein nicht vor 1 1
ich verfolge es und es wenn ich sterbe
oder setzt der schweizer schwein euro
das nächste thema wird richtig
interessant ich bin froh dass da was
haltet ihr von dem bach letzte woche
gestorben oder aber aktuelle team
bringen hier fast gar nichts das wird so
später kommt er erst nächste woche über
nix raus aber zu dick macht kann mir
ganz kurz sagen das ist klar
die schauspieler vielen bekannt alles
gut er ist tot aber jetzt alle dass er
so alles rest in peace dirk bach ich
liebe dirk bach oder war alles also ich
finde es ziemlich übertrieben
die meisten ja gar nicht richtig gekannt
haben und jetzt also nein mein gott
stück paris gestorben ich habe gehört
dass es sich um hilfe ich habe
vielleicht hatten sie hier sein
dschungelcamp kurz geguckt aber sonst
eigentlich auch nichts der soll ja auch
eigentlich vor allem auch ein
ernsthafter schauspieler gewesen sein
und das so eigentlich so dass trash-tv
nur so nebenbei gehabt haben also ich
habe damals bei einer straße gefunden
er ist ja entertainer und so was alles
und dann auf trash tv an sich ist noch
auf theaterschauspieler heute gewesen
von dem schmidt tel portieren euch hat
die passions nicht er mir leider keine
rechte gegeben die hat er kein recht
dpa
er hat jetzt bin
wir gehen jetzt bin ich schon im bett
war so frei geschaltet hat direkt die
sonne einmal ganz kurz vorm ziel gesetzt
so geht es nicht
aber ehrlich gesagt konnte jetzt von
langsam penny ich kann nicht mein bett
ist oft juba dann geht das papier aus er
wartet in meinem bett was soll das
relais und gewachsen legt sich dazu ich
mache mich ab da lang und dann links
schaffst du das bike ins bett gehe ich
jetzt schlafen ja ich habe ihn auch
sonst königsbad gebaut was er da so
getrieben hat sei nach oben in unserer
dna
aber ich will mein bett angucken hatte
es noch abgelehnt
das habe ich gebraucht das bett das habe
ich gebraucht richtig schlafen es ist
spät geworden
helix ein schönes bättig live show nicht
auch schon darf der nachmittag ist was
wegen der privat facebook alle mich als
sie dann hat er freude mischt er
niemanden und nehmen auch niemanden an
also nicht freundschaftsanfrage schicken
muss immer ablehnen jedes mal wenn ich
den 1
anfragen ab entgehen
ich weiß wo wir hingehen
ach mein haus sieht so schön aus
ok wohin ich hoffe und ich ausgerüstet
hier aber ich glaube muss reichen
leon kommt komplett
ich weiß weil mit der nase passt das
alles noch nie gehört
doch nicht aus nein ach so ich denke mit
leon ja okay gut dann kommt den hockey
aufgeht weiß man nicht bringen sagt und
sagt er und sprintete von wohnung jeden
mann du bist